it's friday and i'm not in love all
gonna get down to the dismay of the cure
and rebecca black but i do have gaming
news for you which is definitely better
probably in what is the funniest thing
to happen in gaming this week a hotel
his mistaken HTC a5 screenshot for the
rio los angeles the iconic hotel
figueroa in los angeles has included a
screenshot of GTA 5's los santos on
their webpage mistakenly believing it to
be a photo op la you're a gamer
discovered that the screenshot was
picked up from the firm created GT a
wikia whoever chose said picture appears
to have realized their mistake as it's
now been replaced with ones that
actually detects los angeles or at the
high def GTA 5 mod hard to say you
probably remember back in March when
microsoft said they were happy to
connect xbox legs or other networks
since then all i have been on sony
shortly afterwards owning did reply
saying they're open-minded to
partnerships that didn't directly
address Microsoft's offer to connect
their networks now Xbox co-creator as
razors weighed in saying i hope that
sony is going to respond it's good to
see some of the wall kind of ramping
down more respect and cooperation
between those two groups i'm very
optimistic for the future both companies
rocket league developer psionics have
expressed an interest in enabling xbox
one and ps4 cross-play saying it's not
technically difficult to facilitate what
rather an issue of politics if you have
a pc you're probably aware of the clippy
level annoyance that is Windows 10
pleading to be installed now the thing
is the upgrade is capable of installing
itself unless you hit it on the nose of
the newspaper and tell it know people
aren't so keen on that one such person
was Californian Terry Goldstein who has
successfully sued Microsoft for 10 grand
after her business computer tried to
install windows 10 without her consent
the update failed and she said her
computer slowed to a crawl and would
tend to crash and become unusable for
days at a time after having trouble
contacting Microsoft's customer support
department she opted to take the company
to court claiming lost wages and a
computer Microsoft denied any wrongdoing
but opted to pay out to avoid dragging
out the cake it's been a while since
I've taken some time out to tell you how
to get free [ __ ] both since your wallet
may or may not be empty from the steam
sale here's the free console games you
can pick up in July those of you with an
xbox gold subscription will be able to
grab the banner saga to and tumblestone
for xbox one while xbox 360 users will
be able to pick up rainbow six vegas 2
and tron evolution for free it's worth
noting that those 360 games are playable
on xbox one through backwards
compatibility gives you more of a
playstation person sony are gifting PS
Plus subscribers Saints Row gat out of
hell and fury on ps4 call Suarez bound
in blood and fat princess on ps3 andorra
sugar tainted blood lines and prince of
persia revelation on Rita see Sony's
still care about the Vita sort of
finally if you found yourself off the
internet or trapped under something
heavy yesterday you may not know that
bioshock the collection is coming in
that case here's the lowdown irish rock
bioshock two and bioshock infinite are
getting the remaster treatment as part
of a new anthology for ps4 pc and xbox
one you'll be able to pick up all the
games plus their DLC for 60 bucks come
September 13 in the US also included is
a developer's commentary although it's
worth noting that bioshock throughs
multiplayer has been left out and
bioshock infinite for pc has not been
remastered as 2k say it looks pretty
damn good already all the games will be
arriving in 1080p and will run at up to
60 frames per second across platforms
this week on site be sure to check out
our video on the skyrim mods we want to
see on consoles we crack into the
beginning of inside and chat about where
the resident evil 7 is scary enough you
should let me know down in that comet
bucks what you cared about this week and
do have yourself a lovely week
that I will see you again on Monday